but we have a wonderful forum plan for
you and I'm Ellen Hume and I would like
to welcome you on behalf of David
Thorburn who's the director of the
communications forum and of its
co-sponsors mi t--'s comparative Media
Studies program we have Henry Jenkins
here and on behalf of the Center for
future civic media which I serve as
research director tonight we bring you a
program on youth and civic engagement
and the formative question that we've
posed is has unprecedented access to
information changed young people's
understanding of democracy and maybe
some of you in the group formerly known
as the audience who are now deeply
participatory will come up with good
contributions on this topic in the
second hour of the program the format
will be that our speakers will speak for
15 minutes minutes each and then after
that period we will engage with you for
your questions and comments the MIT
communications forum has been here for I
guess 30 years now and it anjaii invites
the public as well as the MIT community
to a series of conferences and forums on
all aspects of communications but with a
special emphasis on emerging
technologies and this forum as I said is
offered in partnership not only with mi
t--'s comparative Media Studies program
but also with the Center for future
civic media tonight our speakers include
Lance Bennett who's the retic see
Lawrence professor of communication and
professor of political science at the
University of Washington where he
founded and directs his own Center the
center for communication and civic
engagement it sounds a lot like ours so
maybe you can fill us in on what we
should be doing together the center is
dedicated to understanding how
communication processes and technologies
can enhance citizen participation in
social life politics and global affairs
a great mission next to Lance Bennett we
have ingerborg enter who is the outreach
manager of the Center for future civic
media here at MIT and she's a graduate
of the electronic publishing research
group here
at the MIT Media Lab where her research
focused on creating collaborative
community uses of the internet and
ingerborg is here today in particular
because of her experience as program
manager for the computer Clubhouse
Network which is an international
network of after-school activities which
create an environment where young people
from underserved communities use
technology for creative self-expression
we're also very pleased to have with us
Alan KZ house founder and CEO of be the
change a nonpartisan citizens civic
organization and he co-founded and
previously served as the CEO of City
Year a Youth Service Corps which enlists
more than 1200 young adults in 16
communities across America and in
Johannesburg South Africa for a year of
full-time community service Allen and I
first met when he was just a very young
man and I was teaching at Harvard and he
was one of my students then he went on
to become incredibly famous founding
city er which was a model for AmeriCorps
under the Clinton years and we're very
pleased to have tonight as moderator
Mitchel Resnick and he directs the
lifelong kindergarten research group
here at the MIT Media Lab rhetoric and
he serves as head of the media arts and
sciences academic program here he is a
principal investigator for the Center
for future civic media thank you thanks
Allen well it's great to have you here
and it's great to have this assembled
panel to talk on the topic of youth and
civic engagement and I just want to
start with a few comments help frame
some of the session we'll be
participating in today actually the
first thought that I had in thinking
about this panel on youth and civic
engagement was focused on this word
engagement but I think a lot of times
when people think about the role of
youth in their local communities or in
the communities the larger communities
and there's talk there's a lot to talk
about greater levels of involvement and
there's everything people will point to
greater levels of you know voting among
young people in the current cycle or
some greater levels of volunteering and
certain types of commune
servus but a lot of times those measures
give some indication of involvement but
I'd like to make a distinction between
involvement and engagement and we use
the word engagement very specifically it
really goes beyond a type of just
getting involved in community but really
taking an active role of trying to get
your voice heard to bring about a type
of transformational change to see how
you can really get your ideas out to the
world collaborate with others to bring
about meaningful change to those around
you and I think as we think about the
different types of ideas that we'll be
discussing today to think about that
idea of engagement and for me it goes
beyond I know one of the framing
questions was about how well access to
information bring about this change and
I think we want to think beyond just
access to information to be how people
can really bring about take the new
tools to try to shape the changes around
them so it's not just about getting
access to information but shaping the
world around you and that brings to the
second point I'd like to make is the
first one being about going beyond
engagement and the second one another
theme we'll be talking about throughout
the panel is the role of new media in
this type of civic engagement so I'd
like to think we'll continue to see
throughout the panel link between media
engagement and civic engagement and
again we read a lot these days about how
young people are very active with new
media but again I think it's important
to draw the distinction between
involvement and engagement certainly you
see a lot of involvement with media but
I think what we want to be focusing on
with what I would see as media
engagement how people can really take
new media and shape it in a way and use
it to again to get their own voices
heard to bring about change to be able
to be an active to play a real active
role within the community as I thought
about these ideas of civic engagement
and media engagement I thought back
about how much has changed as my own
childhood and some of my own activities
that might have been in this area of you
know some form of getting involved in
local community and certain forms of
civic engagement and media engagement
and thinking about how much things had
changed
I thought about two examples that came
up I must have been about 12 or 13 years
old one of them
as I decided about that age did I wants
to start my own newsletter for the
neighborhood and this might be an early
sign I did spend some years as a
journalist later in my life but at the
age of 12 or 13 I thought be great to
have a newsletter for the neighborhood
to report on what was going on the media
of the time I started using just carbon
paper luck they had very strong bearing
down in my handwriting so I was able to
make quite a few copies with a few
pieces of carbon paper and the big
advance in my newsletter was when I
found out down the street someone had a
memory mimeograph machine but it was a
way for me to try to get my voice heard
to team up with others in the
neighborhood to start thinking about
some of the challenging issues of the
community and to get discussion started
in the community but again certainly had
the limitations of the media of the time
a second thing that I was working on
around that same time at about the same
age was I decided that in our backyard
what we really need in my backyard
was a miniature golf course so I ended
up my parents were tolerant enough to
let me dig up the backyard take piles of
dirt into the walls make a metric golf
course and invite the other kids in the
community of the other kids in there put
over and we had lots of interaction
around building this miniature golf
course interacting together about it and
as a way to bring about a new again
engaging in the community to bring the
young people the community together both
and building this together and then
interacting around it so you might say
some of the core media of my youth were
carbon paper and dirt and I think we've
come a long way from there but it again
it was a right way of getting me started
but if you think about what's possible
today sometimes I think people do think
about the new digital technologies and
they see how did the ways in which would
be different they think about that today
we see all the change it's not using
carbon paper mimeograph machines but you
see lots of teen bloggers who are
writing things they can spread their
voice around the world but for me is
what most of one's not so much they're
spreading the voice around the world but
a greater expressiveness which is
possible today so it's not just the
distance that we reach but the way in
which you really can be more expressive
with your voice and not just have the
the newsletter that I put out but
different ways of creating not just with
videos and music and Sam but simulated
worlds that you can create we've seen
some of that in the centre several
graduate students are using our
brat software worth local kids in the
community who are using it to report on
the issues around their community thinks
they're important to them to be able to
share with the rest the community being
able to do things by creating these
animated similar worlds far beyond what
I was able to do and certainly in the
world of entertainment people being
young people being able to use the new
media to go far beyond you making their
own major golf courses but putting
things online they can bring people
together around different types of
common conversations to bring about
change in their communities so if those
you know comments will turn over to the
panel and we'll go down the table this
way starting with Lance Bennett to hear
some of their comments on the issues of
youth and civic engagement hi it's nice
to be here and thanks for coming on such
a spectacular day it's nice being in and
out on this day so I've been worrying
about the problem of youth engagement
for some long time now because the
future of democracy seems to be at stake
and I believe that citizens ought to be
involved in that future directly and in
important ways and for many young people
politics is a dirty word an unpleasant
concept and the way in which we approach
the teaching about government and
politics in schools doesn't work in fact
some studies suggest that civic
education in many school settings turns
kids off even more so I and I've been
part of that process of trying to get
Civic ed in schools in some ways I've
had very happy success but at very high
cost the amount of resources that we've
found that needs to go into classrooms
to transform them and get kids outside
of classrooms to participate in their
community bring those experiences back
in more than most teachers can manage on
their own and so I've increasingly
turned to after-school programs and to
online communities that involve young
people in the process though I've been
puzzled by the question of what is it
that
is different for young people growing up
in this Democratic Society that makes
politics an edgy proposition and one of
the things that I I think that's useful
is to think about the sort of sweeping
background changes that have gone on
over the last 40 or 50 years in this
society you can attribute them to
globalization effects and we can talk
about what those things really look like
in the daily life terms but if you look
at modernity the the modern society that
is beginning to fade beginning to fall
apart in important ways and I think not
necessarily unhappy ways but just it is
is defined by membership organizations
involving large numbers of people social
hierarchies and many of the
organizations in which people live and
work informally including even the
family and and defined by one way and I
guess the peak moment of the modern era
was the mass society with mass
communication in it and in this has
begun to change to toward what many
giddons and others who have talked about
as a kind of the late modern social
formation in which social networks and
distributed organizations become much
more important sort of person-centered
you know social networks and distributed
organizations which people opt-in and
opt-out and and participatory media
becomes important networking material in
that social formation and I think that
young people have been born into this in
interesting and important ways that
affect their citizenship and their civic
identities so what I see is a kind of a
generational divide you know you can
sort people into categories easily on a
screen more difficult in real life but
for purposes of the quicksort if you
look at young people who've been born
into this late modern society with
participatory media networks and and
loose tied organizations the duty to
participate in government is relatively
weak compared to their parents and
certainly compared to their grandparents
but but there is an interest in politics
but it's an interest on the politics
that are organized around lifestyle
values
environment or consumer politics or
making corporations be more socially
responsible voting may or may not enter
the lifestyle picture Barack Obama seems
to have inspired a lot of people but I
think the inspiration in part comes from
the access to participatory media that
makes them part of the campaign
communication process there's a mistrust
of media conventional media and
politicians
whereas dutiful citizens continue to
watch the news read newspapers older
generation citizens that is loose
networks versus membership organizations
so all of these differences I think are
important for understanding youth
engagement potential in terms of
learning to engage where do kids learn
and where can they learn to engage if
not in classrooms I'm kind of talk about
classrooms you again in a minute I think
that the the predispositions of many
young people there for interactive
sharing of knowledge across peer
networks participation in the creation
of content and a preference for doing
that in democratic environments where
content is created and assessed on a
more egalitarian basis some people may
recoil in horror from that prospect that
knowledge is a collective collaborative
Enterprise on the other hand we might
want to talk about that later on whereas
the the conventional learning styles are
much different hierarchical
authoritative one-way transmission so so
if we think about participatory media as
part of the material of this networked
society in which young people might be
more inclined to engage if they
participate in the content of the
politics that they experience we see
some pretty amazing examples in this
campaign of participatory media that has
large audiences large and
I think youthful audiences would sure
thank all of you for your time your
suggestions your encouragement and your
prayers and I look forward to continuing
our conversation in the weeks and months
to come
hey Bea it's me if you're there pick up
I was just watching you on c-span anyway
call me back you got the idea what's
interesting is that among many things
this has now racked up some eight
million views on YouTube and more in
various mashed-up versions that you can
find in lots of other places than
YouTube it's not participating the sense
that this was a garage band type project
it was done by more professional media
producers but the participation in the
watching it the rating at the sharing it
the viral circulation of it has has I
think been prominent and really quite
interesting
another interesting video that again has
the participatory qualities of rating
sharing mashing up and sending it around
there was Scarlett Johansson and
will.i.am
so while these kinds of things seem to
account for some of the Obama youth
movement what's interesting to me is
here's one of the most watched McCain
YouTube videos keep that faith keep your
courage stick together stay strong
quarter of a million views compared to 8
million about America
that she is worth protecting that
Liberty is priceless
our people honorable our future
prosperous remarkable and free
and what must we believe about that
president what does he think where has
he been
as he walked the walk so and
interspersed with prisoner-of-war images
from from McCain's past but a very
conventional modernist one way it's a
campaign ad and yet this and you'll be
there for the whole season the whole
season you can't do it my friend so this
level of participation
III think offers an important insight
into why Obama has a youth base and and
it also leads me to think that what's
going on by way of learning how to
engage is often going on much more
actively outside of schools which are
the conventional sites of civic
education than inside schools so I'm
recommending that we find ways to follow
the young people where where they are
doing creative things but also to see if
we can facilitate in ways I'm going to
talk about really quickly so that they
can do it more effectively and teach
others so schools have problems
textbook knowledge is incredibly dull
classrooms are not democratic
often politically contested in police
their topics that kids just can't talk
about without having parents start
railing at principals and teachers and
and they're limited in participatory
media access in various ways websites
are censored there's little digital
media skill training and literacy
projects going on in schools that
doesn't mean that online environments
are magic solution at all and I think
that online environments are fraught
with other kinds of problems but because
we have access to creating tools that
can be distributed I think that we have
ways of enhancing those environments so
that's that's really where my interest
in civic learning has gone from schools
to community organizations and now to
distributing tools in community
organizations online environments and in
those cases where schools are willing to
engage with them back to schools but I
think that online environments have
several big problems authenticity many
of the resource bases for designing
youth online environments are government
and NGO funding and control becomes an
issue getting kids to go back to
government immediately before they've
explored in their own ways what their
political interests are turns out to
turn kids off when young people build
their own sites however it's often hard
for them to get audiences so the
question one of the questions that we're
addressing and I would commend you to go
to the MIT press site for a book called
civic life online where a lot of these
issues are raised by interesting authors
that you can download the book for free
so this isn't really a pitch to buy it
and we we are concerned about how kids
can develop sites and get audiences and
not be discouraged if they don't
immediately get audiences for their
blogs or their home-built sites and then
there's across the board a skills
deficit that sites often engaged by
saying do this or join this group but
not really telling kids how to organize
for themselves not talking about how to
define issues to share them to publicize
them
and to take action and to assess action
so there's a whole gamut of skills that
we find missing out there that we think
can be sent around so here's some just
some quick ideas about where we might
promote civic learning online one is a
group of students at the University of
Washington brought this site to our
Center and said can can we can can we
make it live here and and and talk about
it here and I said yeah it's wonderful
and it's called your revolution it's a
facebook application that is sort of
deals with the authenticity in the
audience problem because it's in
facebook which is as everyone knows
highly credible and and it has tens of
millions of users and what this does is
it it asks you about online voting
registration which is available in two
states right now but I think it's coming
soon to a state near you but it's
currently available in Washington
Arizona so this application works in
those two states but since it's housed
in Washington were virally generating it
from from our little Seattle base and
what it does is if you install the
widget and if you go to your Facebook
account you can find the widget just
look for your revolution and it tells
you for example it tells you a lot of
things it asks you things you're
interested in because eventually it's
gonna ask you if you'd like to join
networks of other people interested in
those things on Facebook but it also
tells you of your friends who is and who
isn't registered and then it asks if you
would like to invite your friends to
register and invite your friends who are
registered to see how many of their
friends are and are not registered so
you see the viral possibilities here and
then you can send those friends who live
in Washington and Oregon
online registration pop-up forms so they
can register in Facebook and do other
things as well there are some issues we
might want to talk about such as mache
mning your friends your especially your
Facebook friends a kind of the way we
want to go about getting others to
register to vote
and then there are lots of interesting
related questions another project that
we have going is called becoming
citizens in which University of
Washington undergrads are developing
media skillsets in various areas to help
local regional area teens communicate
about public issues and about their own
community concerns and and some of the
skill sets involved just really basic
things such as online communication what
what makes for good communication do you
have an email turns out lots of kids the
kids we most want to reach don't even
have email and so they're automatically
excluded from a lot of online
environments that might be productive
places for them online safety digital
media literacy public blogging digital
storytelling and then advocacy
strategies and these are just some
snapshots from some of the curriculum
that the students have put together and
they go out and train area kids in how
to use this we're also working on online
versions so we can see if if it works
online to self-trained we've also built
a platform a digital site that actually
we the kids designed that we've
recruited kids from the Seattle area and
offered them some skills so we applied
these skills pretty early on and they
designed a site called Puget Sound off
they named it and designed it and we are
currently rolling out the beta version
of it and it's a place where young
people can come and organize groups
communities do art poetry music talk
about a lot of things that you would do
in a more extended community than just
politics but politics is certainly in
the mix so this is what it looks like
this is their design and these are some
of those stories
we've got a community going on hip-hop
music and not just the music part of
hip-hop but also questions of misogyny
and hip-hop and the politics of hip-hop
so kids are beginning to organize
networks to talk about that abusive
relationships turned out to be an
important issue for a lot of kids who
have figured out there in one or they
know someone who's in one and they want
to talk about how you deal with that and
and so these are examples of some of our
videos and some of the issue networks
that are coming so I'm going to end with
what what the kids produced as the
public service announcement for this
site and and this this is a video that
they produced themselves but I think it
conveys the sense of how they understand
their own ideal digital media
environment and this is what they did
except that it's not working yeah I'll
tell you what I think I've got a copy of
it on my desktop
see if this works
yeah
oops
where's that all there's the play button
but I can't sitting down here nice huh
spacebar second do it it's not doing it
what's being done to stop poverty in
Seattle who else believes that President
Bush is an alien sound off
so those are some ideas and I welcome
your questions at the end thanks so next
to be ingerborg enter actually I should
have explained at the beginning that the
format will have each of the presenters
speak for 15 minutes or so then after
the discussion will then turn to the
audience thanks Ellen to explain that
say ingerborg good evening it's great to
see the audience I'm going to talk this
evening about a topic that's quite dear
to me and it is a very apropos topic for
civic and youth civic engagement and
that is the computer Clubhouse I worked
at the computer Clubhouse for about
seven years and worked with many many
communities around the world so I'll
give you a little taste of what's going
on in civic engagement in the clubhouses
first I'll say that one of the reasons
that club houses are important in this
topic of civic engagement is that every
clubhouse is rooted in their community
that's part of the point of how
Clubhouse is operate the clubhouse
network was started in 1993 the first
clubhouse was started in 1993 as a joint
venture between Mitchell Resnick's
lifelong kindergarten group here at the
Media Lab and what was then the computer
museum and now has merged with the
Museum of Science in Boston so the
clubhouse is infused and from it's very
beginnings in constructionist learning
philosophy and what we call the learning
model is one of the key aspects of the
clubhouse learning style
so we support in the clubhouse we
support youth learning through design
experiences it's learning by doing the
young people are typically age is 10 to
about 18 they do work with very high-end
equipment high-end computers and other
types of equipment we help youth build
on their own interests and that's very
important too because young people are
very passionate about and get very very
involved and engaged with things that
they care about the other important
thing is to cultivate an emergent
community of learners within a clubhouse
there are adults in the clubhouse
there's usually one or two paid staff
but many club houses have a variety of
adult mentors who come and work with the
young people and they have various
skills some of them are graphics
professionals computer science people
some of them don't know a lot about
computers and come to more engage with
with the young people and so it's a
community where people learn from each
other and so the adults often learn as
much from the young people as the other
way around so it's not a hierarchical
learning community creating an
environment of trust and respect is very
important our target audience for
computer clubhouses our underserved
youth in the beginning most of the club
houses were in inner cities now as the
clubhouse network has grown we have
quite a number of club houses in rural
areas as well but young people in those
communities are often not trusted and
very often not respected so to come to a
place where they feel safe both
creatively and physically is very very
important for them and it's an important
community experience for them to find
that there
adults who trust them who let them use
equipment without a lot of caveats and
oh no don't do that no is not a word we
use very often in the clubhouse and we
find that this respect and mutual trust
often makes know not very relevant one
of the last important things is
empowering youth with skills and
self-actualization the sense that they
can do these various things that they
thought only professionals could do and
that in turn enriches communities and we
feel that that's a really important part
of what club houses are all about the
club has now the clubhouse network now
has 104 club houses in 21 countries and
you probably can't read all the country
names but as you see we're all over the
world and the flagship Clubhouse the
original club clubhouse is located now
at the Museum of Science here in Boston
and the clubhouse staff who interact and
help club houses get started all over
the world are based also at the Museum
of Science and there's a lot more that
one can say but I'm just trying to give
you a taste of what this is I'm going to
give you a quick tour by the clubhouse
members themselves which think will give
you a better flavor there's a clubhouse
in Harlem in New York City and they the
clubhouse members got together to make a
video to welcome a new clubhouse that
was coming into the network from
Johannesburg in South Africa so I'm
going to play that for you we have sound
well I really wanted to get into it it's
a really good environment it's really a
really cool place you get to do a lot of
different things you can build a website
mostly yeah what I do here is right
you could go to kids pigs you can make
your own gangs here I'm like a joke
person so I like to make funny things
put my face and I got one of my favorite
baseball players
it makes your mind flow I did this one
first then next I connected and it came
out like this I love taking pictures you
can even make your own movies here
so whatever you want added it color it
make it move scat special effects to
everything that's a big time when we
produce it though you can do it go to
studio make up simple beats and just put
it together alright so the kids are much
more fluent about what they love so the
civic engagement part for the early
years of the clubhouse and often the
early days of a clubhouse members
experience in a clubhouse it's all about
their own creative expression and it's
about collaboration the the young people
work in groups most of the time although
they do spend a lot of time really
focused on a particular job that they're
working on
often their projects are quite
collaborative but recently there has
been a real upsurge in in clubhouse
communities where club houses are
becoming much more involved in their
neighborhoods and in their larger
communities in many cases club houses
are actually serving as a community
center all of them are based in a
community organization they'll be in
boys and girls clubs they're in food
banks they're in local community centers
but often the clubhouse becomes the
focal point for community to get
together and different community groups
meet there and the children are often
translators helpers and and and they
help to bring that community together
I'll tell you a couple of short stories
that there are this is just a teaser
there are many other wonderful stories
of community engagement and clubhouses
the preserving traditions on tribal
lands is about a clubhouse in Arizona
which is on tribal lands and they're all
Native Americans there and the young
people engaged some of the elders in
recording their traditional songs now
this had never been done before because
it was not allowed that these things
should be recorded but because it was
their children and grandchildren who had
requested this and because those
children and grandchildren had the
technical skills the recording studio
the equipment and the skills to use them
they did record some of the traditional
songs and that was very important for
the community in Dublin a clubhouse in
Blanchard's town which is a town within
the city of Dublin local elections were
coming up and a lot of the young people
were talking about the fact that many of
the things that were being voted on
affected them very much and yet they
couldn't vote and they felt they really
didn't have a voice in what was
happening so they organized a voting day
where they invited the candidates for
all the local council offices to come to
the clubhouse and the young people set
up stations where they put their own
issues and they put them in in music and
various other media but their point was
to let their voices be heard by the
candidates even if they couldn't vote
for the candidates they could tell the
candidates what young people were
concerned about more thinking about and
what what they cared about and finally
there's a wonderful story about the
clubhouse in San Paulo in Brazil which
is in again a very underserved community
in what we would call a slum and they
decided to get together and try to
beautify their neighborhood very local
neighborhood and so they worked on the
plans for this for quite a while and
decided to to create an art project
where they would beautify the lens so
I'm gonna show you this is a very long
video and I'm not going to show you the
whole thing but I'm going to show you a
little bit and I'll talk over it a
little bit while it's running
so the idea was that they were going to
create a art alley so with an
apprenticeship project where they were
apprenticed to some local artists or
into being introduced here and the idea
was for them to create murals on this
art alley and they worked for weeks now
you're you're seeing the finished
product here but they work for weeks to
plan this to plan the themes create the
stencils do the designs do the actual
painting we did a lot of work in the
clubhouse in preparation for this before
it before it actually became real
we also created a music piece song which
is
so that's our Clubhouse in Brazil so
those that's just a few little teasers
there are many other wonderful stories
and one of the things that I think about
a lot now that I'm involved in the
Center for future Civic Media is what a
rich rich host of environments these
club houses are as potential areas for
civic engagement in their communities
and I hope we can be a good partner with
them and create a lot of opportunities
in the future thank you and they will
pass on to Alan Kay say good evening
everybody it's a great two beer I want
to thank Ellen for inviting me as she
said I was a student of hers when I was
in college years and years ago when she
was teaching at Harvard and she was a
wonderful teacher and mentor him become
good friends and so when she asked me to
come to join you here at the Media Lab I
was very excited to join you also I love
this institution
I love MIT my father-in-law teaches here
in the physics department jr. lab my
daughter's learn to swim here at your
wonderful pool and I'm just so inspired
by what the Media Lab is doing in this
whole new effort around civic engagement
and young people I used to be a young
leader I still work with a lot of young
people so I think that's why Ellen asked
me to be here I do not pretend to be an
expert on young people in civic
engagement but I am working on a new
project which I want to share with you
and I am totally inspired I'm inspired
by the stuff that Lance talked about and
that ingerbord talked about what's going
on here and what we're seeing that's
emerging so I'd like to talk to you
about this new effort that I've launched
called be the change
just quickly I want to talk to you bout
my own personal journey I want to share
with you thoughts about the need for a
new public philosophy a new methodology
for making change and a new generation
of entrepreneurs my own journey where I
came from as a Mitch mentioned ICO fund
organization called City Year a little
over 20 years ago with my college
roommate and best friend Michael Brown
and city or whole idea was to try to be
an action tank a model for national
service our vision was that we would get
to a place in our country where the most
commonly asked question of an 18 year
old would be where you're gonna do your
service year and I spent some time
working in presidential politics and on
Capitol Hill in the early 1980s when I
was in college and right out of college
and as did my partner Michael and
everybody said to us even people that
liked the idea said well how do you know
what can work and there was a lot of
movement around the idea of national
service the early 1980s various programs
getting started and we said well let's
try and create an organization that
could help to role model back to
actually show people that you could this
is when you know young people were
branded the Me Generation yuppies greed
is good all that stuff going on in the
country we didn't believe any of that
that our peers we just felt that people
weren't asking them to serve could you
get people to do it could you get the
private sector help pay for it could
young people 18 19 20 do anything of
value and so we decide to set up City
Year it's for young people aged 17 to 24
to dedicate themselves for a year to
full-time community service started in
nineteen eight right here in Boston with
50 young people for a summer and today
it's over 1,500 people operating in 17
cities in America and in South Africa
and we did help to play a role in
inspiring AmeriCorps and I did that for
almost 20 years and the turning point
for me was just about five years ago now
in June of 2003 the AmeriCorps program
which had been going on at that point
for about ten years was cut by 80
percent overnight and not because of
anything that a single one of the more
than a thousand AmeriCorps programs
around the country did but we because of
partisan
and bureaucratic mismanagement in
Washington
80% funding cut the week that they were
supposed to announce the grants they
said oh I'm sorry we just don't have the
money and so I got together with some
friends in the service movement and we
organized this big campaign to save him
and we did sort of a grass tops and a
grassroots effort basically leveraging
our collective networks around that and
the good news was is that we got half
the money back for that year so that
programs could sort of continue and then
we got all the money back for the
following year plus one hundred million
dollars which was a big increase the
program overall was funded at about
three hundred million dollar level so
it's a very significant increase to make
up for the cuts and in response to this
big campaign we did we did grass tops we
got 44 governor's we got 150 mayors we
got a hundred editorials written and you
know starting right here at the Boston
Globe and in the grassroots side we did
a citizen petition we did rallies around
the country and and the big thing we did
was we sort of did mr. Smith comes to
Washington made real we brought citizens
from 47 states including Alaska came to
Washington and we did a hundred hours of
round-the-clock testimony we essentially
did a citizen's hearing on Capitol Hill
straight through the night for more than
four days because we figured if we
couldn't get our leaders in Washington
come visit these programs and see the
impact we'll bring him to them and that
effort led to this restoration that was
the good news the bad news is we all
went back to our day jobs which was not
to run this kind of advocacy effort of
this grass stops grassroots effort it
was to run these programs and every year
since it's been cut not by 80% way about
10 to 10 to 15% and by the time this
administration leaves office we'll be
right back to where we were and so
watching that I thought you know there's
got to be another way
to make change my initial idea was to
sort of create City to help bring about
universal national service but there's
got to be a better way so I went back
and thought about Gandhi and I'm a
student of Gandhi and Gandhi had a three
fold strategy for building a fair just
democratic society what he called the
spinning wheel the ballot in the jail
the spinning wheel is service and Gandhi
she said it started with that it's what
Sears about it's what AmeriCorps it's
about it's about what people will are
willing to do to just get involved and
try to make a difference in their
communities and it starts there but he
also said there were two other legs to
the stool the ballot in the jail the
ballot for Gandhi was political activity
you know not just voting but getting
involved in the political and policy
process and then the jail was civil
disobedience or mass citizen action
which is ultimately how Gandhi led India
to freedom it's what Ron that their King
did in the civil rights movement here
and so what I'm trying to do now with
this new organization is can you put
that sort of theory of change into
action with be the change and it's in a
context of where we are today I think we
need a new public philosophy we need a
new approach to solving problems and if
you think about it in the past 75 years
we've lived essentially under to public
philosophies first you had FDR who in
his second inaugural address after
serving as president for four years said
I have complete faith in the capacity of
government to solve problems once
considered unsolvable and we basically
lived under that public philosophy
through Republicans and Democrats until
Ronald Reagan and Ronald Reagan came in
with his inaugural address and said just
the opposite government isn't the
solution it's the problem so you know
full circle from FDR and even Clinton
who was a Democratic president you know
he said 1996 the era of big government
is over and so I think what we need now
is a new public philosophy how do we
solve problems and this is what this
whole notion I think of civic engagement
is about and what are we gonna do in the
21st century well I think the elements
of that new public philosophy are
threefold first of all and this is what
excites me so much about this this topic
we need massive citizen engagement we
are living at an unprecedented time for
citizens to become involved I think in
two ways both in service through a
universal voluntary national service
program that's what I've been working on
for the past 20 years we're you know
when people turn 18 they'd be
challenging given the opportunity to
spend a year in full-time service but
then also people continuing to volunteer
and be involved through their lives
cities
on mass attacking problems that's one
piece the other piece of it and Lance
talked about this and ingebord talked
about even with her students we also
need people to start doing what harry
truman challenged us to do when he left
the White House there's a famous story
that when Truman left the White House a
reporter called out to him and said mr.
president what are you gonna do now that
you're leaving the highest office in the
land and Truman who was one of the most
humble people who ever hold that office
didn't aspire to it right away responded
I'm not leaving the highest office I'm
assuming the highest office that of
citizen now what did he mean by that not
just service but not just voting but
being engaged being involved caring
about issues committing yourself feeling
that you actually have an office as a
citizen and I think what's going on now
with technology in particular and with
young people if people could start
holding that office that's key to a new
public philosophy the second thing I
think is we need a new system for social
entrepreneurship I won't get into this
in detail but there's just this
abundance of social entrepreneurs who
are inventing new solutions Teach for
America City or Public Allies jump start
citizen schools a lot of them started
right here in Boston by the way year up
Bell Youth build Harlem Children's Zone
it's it's extraordinary but what we need
to do is we need to build a system to
scale those things own that's akin to
the private sector system for
entrepreneurs I think that I spent a
year traveling around the world ten
years ago and what my wife and I Vanessa
Kirsch discovered was is that the reason
at least our theory was the reason we
dominate the global economy is because
we have the best entrepreneurial system
if you're an entrepreneur we have a such
a great system people leave other
countries to come here like the Google
guys to start their companies because we
have such a great system we need a
similar system so that when a Wendy Kopp
invents a Teach for America it doesn't
take 20 years to just get to 5,000
teachers when we have a shortage we're
gonna have over the next ten years of
two million we're gonna two million new
teachers it should be scaled up much
faster she's getting now for example
30,000 people the best and the brightest
applying to Teach for America she only
has the resources to take 5,000 so we
need to have a system that will scale up
these innovations and then finally I
think we need to have a new role for
government and
new role for the nonprofit and private
secretary new partnerships that
understand
FDR may have been right for his time but
government alone can't solve these
problems but also understand that what
Reagan said doesn't apply to today
either and I think I think the end of
the Reagan philosophy was Katrina I
think we all realized when we saw like
thousands of our fellow citizens you
know abandoned and if you've been to New
Orleans by the way even two and a half
years later there hasn't been enough
progress at all in the richest country
in the world when you have denigrated
government for 27 years government
failed at every level federal state
local and it's interesting it's actually
been a lot of the voluntary groups that
have come in but I think we all sort of
woke up and realized okay that
philosophy isn't working anymore either
and it's a new time so I think we need a
new public philosophy how does this
connect
I think the Millennials are gonna lead
us to this new public philosophy they
are a different generation
they are looking at problem-solving in a
different way they are they have the
potential to be the next greatest
generation they are volunteering and
participating at higher rates than any
other generation 50 of them million of
them are gonna be voters and they are
turning on I mean Lance talked about
this it's interesting there are new ways
to participate you see what's happening
with the Obama campaign in terms of
appealing to young voters in particular
and the 70% of them still believe
politics is relevant 84 percent of young
people are paying significant attention
to the presidential campaign that's up
from just 58 percent from just a year
ago so they are getting engaged by 2018
the Millennials will be 90 million
strong the baby boomers who have
dominated this country for the past 30
40 years are 75 million strong the
Millennials are gonna overtake and you
know the impact the baby boomers have
had money is are gonna overtake the baby
boomers and 71% of the think political
engagement is an effective way of
solving important issues but they're
they're interesting they're not as
ideological they're more about what
works they're more about can we get
solutions and push those so what I'm
trying to do is be the changes is look
at a new methodology for attacking
problem
and part of our hope is to engage the
Millennials but frankly engage all
citizens who are interested in this I
mentioned that and our approach is
something that I'm calling meta Action
tanking and what I mean by this is how
do you affect policy change in this
country well we have think tanks and
they're effective and they can work and
their strategy is basically get really
smart people who will come up with
really good ideas then they sort of do
their advocacy efforts with elites in
Washington usually or if they're the
state level elites at the state level
what Michael I did was see around what
some other social interest is trying to
do is become action tanks we sort of
took the think tank idea around a
particular issue national service what
should it look like and then put it into
action and use that to help inspire a
new public policy in our case it was
AmeriCorps and what you can do with that
what I've learned now after 20 years of
trying to push city air to universal
national service is that an organization
is in action tank can often bring about
policy innovation but it's hard to
affect the whole system and what I
learned from the same AmeriCorps crisis
was what I'm now calling meta action
tanking what what what saved AmeriCorps
was that all these different groups all
these different organizations and then
citizens and leaders who cared combined
their efforts combined their resources
and that was enough to affect the system
and interestingly when those cuts first
happened we talked to the political
leaders in Washington even our friends
and they said sorry there's nothing we
can do about it we're not in power
there's a war going on there's a massive
budget deficit and you know this is a
good program but but once the sort of
grass tops and the grass roots got
engaged the system moved and the program
was saved and so this is sort of the but
the key to this is ultimately the grass
stops and the grass roots is can you get
enough critical mass of citizens who
care around big issues to move the
system and I think that's what the this
sort of new opportunity presents us I
also think when it comes to the
Millennials we are on the cusp of a new
breed of entrepreneurs that are emerging
what I call civic advocacy entrepreneurs
for lack of a better word and here's an
analogy the echoing green foundation
with only three
a year provided essentially the venture
capital and it was started by a venture
capitalist the social venture capitalist
who launched a whole generation of these
incredible social entrepreneur ghen is a
shion's all with grants of about a
hundred thousand dollars over two years
it's basically here's just money so
frankly you can tell your parents
actually you can pay your rent and you
can you know afford to your food and you
can just dedicate yourself full time of
your project you look at these things
that have been spawned by echoing green
bell project health Global Fund for
Children Ella Baker Center of Human
Rights jumpstart Public Allies Teach for
America College summit city etc it's
extraordinary the social
entrepreneurship movement has a lot of
steam and it's growing and it's needed
and as I said I think we need a whole
new system for that and we need young
people and older people to continue to
be social entrepreneurs but there's a
new thing that's emerging on the
landscape what I'm calling civic
advocacy entrepreneurs and it's being
driven by the millennial generation and
what's interesting they've come up age
at a different time they've come up of
age participating in the service of it
this has had an effect there's been 20
years now of a service movement and a
lot of them get involved in service and
they get turned on to an issue it's
amazing the number of Teach for America
alumni for example that have become
leaders in education reform starting
charter schools Michelle Rhee was the
superintendent of schools in DC as a TFA
alum the people who started the Kipp
academies etc and that's just one you
know example they've had their defining
events have been different 9/11 Katrina
the tsunami these gigantic events all
happening within a space of just a few
years they're defining issues are much
bigger and they're global and they they
require a different kind of approach
it's not just you know it takes a global
cooperation frankly whether it's aids
global warming climate change war on
terrorism
the globalization etc and they're
growing up in an atmosphere of web 2.0
as Lance talked about Facebook MySpace
YouTube Google the whole open-source
revolution and it's a very different
kind of of world they're emerging into
and they're driving it and what's
happening is you're starting to get
these younger people who are becoming
advocacy on other words they see an
issue and unlike social entrepreneurs
they're not just trying to certain
organization to solve it they were
building advocacy networks there's a
group step it up that was six students
right on a Miller but Middlebury who
launched a national day of action around
climate change happened a year ago
almost exactly in April that has now led
to one sky which got launched for 50
million dollars to fight climate change
it's all about a grassroots movement
there's another group just once more
minute there's another group genocide
intervention network started on a
college campus at Haverford with a few
students it's now got a thousand
chapters on college campuses and they
are one of the key leading groups in the
whole Save Darfur effort there's others
that are coming there's serve next I
won't go into this started by three city
or alumni three people full-time they
got every single Democratic candidate to
pledge to grow AmeriCorps by a hundred
thousand people more than doubling the
program McCain doesn't sign pledges but
he said I've got a bill that will do
better than that and they've had more
impact on the national service issue
than the thousand AmeriCorps programs
because they're having an advocacy
approach so I guess I would conclude
with just saying that this is an
incredibly exciting time things are
being invented it's moving so quickly
it's hard to even keep track of it but
that I think it's important that we
figure out new ways to support
especially the millennial generation
through this kind of civic advocacy
effort that we think about new ways to
engage citizens to get involved in the
policy and political process and that we
keep open to the kind of you know
revolutionary change that's possible if
we continue to encourage it thank you
thank the panelists in May I'll kick it
off with one question then we'll open it
up to the audience to ask other
questions one thing was going through my
mind as I was listening and we hear some
great examples of you know how young
people gain deeply engaged with bringing
in their communities bringing about
change and we see the great potential
and a tremendous interest and a growing
interest I think we'd all agree with
Alan you're from young people today you
know we also hear as
was saying that there isn't issue about
learning to engage even if there's this
great interest it doesn't mean that
things will just happen automatically
I'd like to ask the panelists what is it
that needs to be done if we were if
there still is a child how to help
people learn to engage and become
engaged civically what are the most
important things we can do as a society
to support and to help support that type
of learning to engage a lot for example
we just as educators have spent decades
coming up with learning standards for
schools we could think about learning
standards for civic environments online
and and what's what new ones do we need
if citizenship and identity are changing
and online communities offer different
kinds of political organization
potential what kinds of learning
opportunities could be promoted and then
what kinds of skills I think civic
skills are really important a lot of
kids don't know what a blog is why
they'd ever use one perhaps by the time
we've taught kids how to blog nobody
will be blogging anymore but that's not
really the the problem it's to encourage
kids to communicate effectively to
organize how do kids know how to
organize mean the entrepreneurs are
exceptional but I would like to see more
kids become exceptional in an
entrepreneurial way so all of those
things and then to become advocates for
their causes and which kids I mean I
think there are a lot of kids who are at
risk for doing these things and I would
like to think very hard about how to get
more of the kids who are unlikely to
want to or imagine they can participate
to become effective advocates for issues
that are really important to them so
there's a whole set of things that we
all of us can can do just reference just
talking about I think one way is if we
did Institute if we had more of a
universal voluntary national service
system starting in kindergarten you know
so there's service-learning in all
schools and then with an opportunity for
full time participation at that sort of
critical life age 18 to 25 and then
ongoing opportunities all the way
through the boomer years but what we've
found with city or is that our graduates
vote
much higher rates than their peers they
continue to be to volunteer much higher
rates they contribute and they don't
make a lot of money because a lot of
them go in the nonprofit sector but they
contribute to political and other causes
at four times the rate of their peers
they maintain and develop friendships
people from diverse backgrounds 90 plus
percent of them do that they are much
more active citizens it does work if you
spend a year essentially as a full-time
active duty citizen when you're doing
national service you become more
civically engaged as a new study that
the Corporation for National Service is
going to be putting out just in a couple
of weeks that actually has similar data
for AmeriCorps as a whole so one way to
do this is if we did have a more
universal national service opportunity
people would learn these skills you
can't you can't learn citizenship by
just reading about it in a book and I
think what Lance was talking about we
got to change how we teach is right on
you got to do it the second thing as I
mentioned we need to come up with new
ways to support young people who want to
do civic advocacy because with these
entrepreneurs like I mentioned you know
genocide intervention Network it started
with a handful of people at Haverford
it's now a thousand chapters on campuses
but because what the entrepreneurs do is
they build these organizations that then
give other people a chance to be
involved they don't you know and so if
we could come up with new if
philanthropists and others said you know
what we're gonna help fund these things
the way I come in green is done with
social entrepreneurs the young people
themselves and you could give these
grants even at college they'll be given
a high school level the young people
themselves will develop the
organizations that will then get their
peers involved to become more civically
engaged
as an underpinning to what both lance
and Alan said I'm thinking about younger
children and what we can do for younger
children to encourage them to have the
skills that they'll need to organize and
and to be good citizens and I see some
projects emerging in our Center right
now that are that are built around
storytelling and learning empathy and
understanding your community
understanding who you are within your
community and understanding the dynamics
of your community in the history of your
community and I think with middle school
well from from as young as necessary as
soon as children start learning both in
after-school environments and in school
environments I believe it's really
important to stress those skills of
understanding both ourselves and where
we come from and and the history of our
communities so I think it's it's very
interesting to see that a lot of
projects are emerging along those lines
let's make one comment when lance was
mentioning about learning to organize
one thing is striking to me in the
current presidential campaign first of
all I think it's rather remarkable for
the first time having a leading
presidential candidate who started out
early as life as a community organizer
but one is even more striking is in
conversations I've had is how little
people understand what it means to be a
community organizer so I think the fact
that Obama was a comedian people don't
really have a real sense of that of what
it means and to me it just touches on
the fact that people don't have a real
sense of the activity of organizing and
being actually engaged in community and
so it highlights the importance of a
type of helping to get get feel better
understand help will develop a better
understanding of ways they can be
involved in community so let's turn to
the audience there I think there are
microphones in a couple sides who would
just raise your hand and the microphones
can
hello my name is Emily Lin I'm a student
at the Harvard Graduate School of
Education and a Reynolds fellow in
social entrepreneurship my I have two
questions the first one is pretty short
I'm just wondering what you think the
unique role of youth is in civil society
traditionally it seems maybe that their
role is for labor and then also to
provide security for the older
generation but it seems maybe there's a
shift in the way you're talking about
youth voice being expressed so how are
you
youth unique in civil society as opposed
to adults who may also be using these
tools second question is about scale and
the relationship between the public and
public and private sector in terms of
getting to scale I think in the
Roosevelt generation scale was
definitely seen as a public effort and
now it seems there's a shift to the
private sector for example using
Facebook for authenticity and audience
as you were talking about and to me
that's there are a lot of interesting
opportunities there but there are also a
lot of pitfalls so I was wondering if
you could speak to that thank you two
really great questions an anecdote about
the role of youth that mean I think
youth voice has not typically been loud
or particularly effectively organized
but the the professionalization of the
political communication process has
depressed it even more because
professional campaign managers typically
have not addressed messages to young
people because they're not cost
effective and so so that means that
young people are not invited to vote by
most candidates bama's an interesting
exception and indeed giving them
networking capacities isn't even more
interesting move I think but but in
terms of what the youth voice could be I
think we're also seeing it in some of
the participatory media networking
that's going on in this campaign it's a
very interesting voice I mean it makes
the campaign more fun and it's more
engaging it's something that young
people are creating content in which is
unusual and I think they're doing it
very effectively but I think that
there's an even bigger civil
Society role for young people I mean our
schools are a catastrophe I mean it's a
shame on this nation and who suffers it
most students and and and how can we
help students become advocates for
school reform I think could be an
enormous Lee I mean that's just one
example of how young people could have
an enormous ly effective voice if given
the skills to to learn to express it in
focused and and really high-impact ways
so I think that youth voice could be
much more creative and probably convince
people more than our current efforts at
school reform are doing because they're
obviously not working
so as for Facebook and the
commercialization process also very
important question there are limits in
facebook the the students who did your
revolution and got that widget into
Facebook had to go through a lot of
negotiations with Facebook to change
some of the limits that Facebook imposes
on those kinds of viral possibilities
and one of the reasons that we're
building a platform in Seattle that's
non-commercial is to make sure that it
stays that way and that the
commercialization doesn't creep in but
but kids are in facebook and so I think
it's important to go there as well
well Emily an answer to your first
question I think that's a really tough
one because I see many areas where youth
are really empowered and much more so
than in in older among older generations
but I see a great disparity this the
sorts of social engagement and all the
organizations that are bubbling up that
Alan mentioned is a really encouraging
phenomenon and it is bubbling down to
younger people but I see a really great
disparity among the economic situation
of young people even though many people
feel that the digital divide is no
longer a big issue
the economic divide is becoming a much
huger issue and I think among young
people who are not as privileged who
don't have computers at home who don't
have the kind of really good education
that the more privileged youngsters get
that to me is is really disturbing
because and that's one of the reasons
why I find what I see happening in
computer Clubhouse is so powerful is
because these are usually the young
people who are not empowered who are
often ignored because of their financial
status so I think that in general there
is a movement to empower young people
much more and often it's their own
energy that's doing that empowering but
I do think we leave too many behind
because of the economic disparities I
think that's absolutely right ingerbord
thing I would just add I think the role
for young people in civil society is
absolutely essential and you know
historically young people have always
been at the forefront of big efforts for
change Martha King was 26 when he led
their Montgomery bus boycott Nelson
Mandela was 26 when he co-founded the
ANC Youth League Alice Paul was 28 when
she co-founded the Congressional Union
for women's suffrage Cesar Chavez was 19
when he started his first labor union
but it wasn't just those leaders it was
the young people who went and did the
sit-ins and the marches and the Freedom
Rides and civil rights of his young
people who led the effort on the
environmental movement it was young
people who led the effort to you know
against the war it's always been young
people because you know face it as you
get older you took you know you get if
you're married you have a house you got
children you just get a you're just not
able to have the time be you just get
more conservative you you you start to
lose your sense of what's possible and
so I think it's very important that
that's why I'm so thrilled about what's
happening politically this year and I
think you know what what Lance was
talking about like this Puget Sound off
and this online voting the tools
are available now for young people to
organize and get their voice heard are
unprecedented
and I think all of us who have a chance
need to encourage that and push them to
frankly hold us all accountable to the
kind of world that we could have in
terms of the scaling question you're
absolutely right and this gets back to
what I was talking about for intro as a
new role for government it used to be
that we scaled the government scale
government programs and that's what we
look to I think we need now is we do
need to scale things that's a key issue
but government has to change from
scaling government programs to providing
money to scale social entrepreneurial
efforts to scale great nonprofits to
scale new public-private partnerships so
rather than the government doing it all
itself and again I don't think it's all
government of FDR and it's no government
at Reagan it's a new role where if you
can show measurable results like a Teach
for America or a jump start or citizen
schools or Harlem Children's Zone or a
whole number of things that actually do
work and get results Bell foundation
that the government will take its money
and help to scale those things in a very
strategic way most government funding is
either done on formula basis which is
just population or politically it's not
focused on what we're and you know what
works what doesn't work and how do we
really take these things to scale and
that's a key key issue especially as
we're trying to solve these problems
other questions hi my name is fawn and I
have a question following up on what
Engelberg and her was saying about
empowering youth my question is I used
to mentor at the clubhouse when I was a
student and when I got a day job I
couldn't do it anymore because I
couldn't be there during the hours when
it was open so my question is how can we
as citizens help to support the
empowerment of youth in a grassroots way
that's a very good question
thank you fine but it's hard I know in
club houses and and you've experienced
this yourself as a mentor it's very
difficult to get mentors because of our
Clubhouse ours Clubhouse is typically
open after school around 3:00 they go to
six or seven or eight depending on the
community but often those are the hours
when when working people are working and
we rely very heavily in areas where
there are students we rely on graduate
students college students we rely on
retired people in some places and
another really great resource is the
young people themselves when they grow
too old to be considered members they
graduate from high school and then they
they're not considered members anymore
and they don't want to leave so they're
they're sort of graduated to become
mentors but even they've become involved
in jobs and and other responsibilities
and can't do it and I think you know you
Alan you might have some ideas about the
whole social volunteerism social change
it requires a lot of people it's hard
sometimes to get the manpower the
womanpower that you need because of as
you said people become busy they have
other responsibilities so I would say
that an interesting example that I've
seen it some club houses as companies
who give their employees a certain
amount of free time during the days to
allow them to volunteer in places like
that flexibility like that in the
workplace might be a good solution but
it is it is an issue for I believe many
many social organizations that are
working for change
if you have answers problem people say
when you have a you know if your hammer
everything's a nail I mean my big issues
national service and so I think you know
one way to do this is if we had a system
where a million young people a year were
in full-time service I mean we've seen
it's it's it's been modeled now in a
small way with AmeriCorps there's 70,000
a year but what with those full-time
people do a they can help coordinate
volunteers so because it does take work
you know even if even if you want to
volunteer where do you go how do you
sign up what hours can you fit them in
are the materials there if to help you
know so that's one thing they could do
they can also do a lot of the direct
service work I mean you know we what we
realized was City or is that that age
group 17 to 24 is the perfect age group
for kids who are 6 to 16 because they're
young enough that they can still relate
they know what music they're listening
to and what clothes are hot and who the
hip-hop artists are and all that stuff
but they're old enough that those
younger kids look at them as total role
models and so if we had a more scaled up
system you could provide that kind of
person power and then it gets back to
how do you mentor young people and how
do you get them engaged well the best
people to be doing it are people who are
you know not much older than they are
and who can help encourage them and
relate to them and hey you could solve a
lot of problems with that energy but you
it's a continual sort of youth mentoring
youth and youth bringing along youth
resource and then the other thing that
we've seen is once people do that then
they continue to be those volunteers as
they go and I think work-release time as
a number of companies are doing that I
also think the next big frontier for
service by the way is the baby boom
generation people are living longer
they're healthier they've got incredible
skills and that there should be a new
opportunity in particular to encourage
and support baby boomers who aren't
retiring and we're looking for encore
careers to get involved in these and one
thing that does come to my mind is just
the importance of not just thing of how
individuals get involved in community
but how institutions get involved in
their local communities so some of the
things they're talking about about work
release time I mean there are a lot of
companies now is
part of a sense of corporate
responsibility make donations to their
local community they're far fewer who
will give the flexibility for their
employees to get deeply engaged and in
my mind that would be even more
important I mean obviously don't want to
cut off the corporate contributions as
well but certainly that I think to to
rethink what it means for institutions
to be meaningfully involved in their
local communities and having their
employees play important roles such as
you know mentoring or you know teaching
apprenticeships of citizen schools could
be really perhaps one of the most
important ways also the way schools get
engaged in their local communities there
are too many schools that you know you
know you know you know shut their doors
you know at the end when the last bell
rings where in fact they could be
round-the-clock community centers and we
start to see some of that happening but
a real challenge and that there are all
these different you know rules and
regulations and constraints to make it
difficult for schools as institutions to
get more deeply engaged in the community
where in fact they really could play an
important role of helping people of all
ages you know it you know later hours in
the afternoon and the evening come
together in ways hi my name is Jason a
graduate student in CMS and Mitchell you
actually bring up a good point which is
that there are a lot of rules and
regulations and I think that the
Millennials are succeeding in their sort
of you know they're active engagement in
in spite of who's my sound here in spite
of the government not you know because
of it and I think that the quote that
you mentioned earlier Alan about Reagan
you know the government is the problem
not the solution and I think that that's
an attitude that's still very much held
by young people in many regards and this
particular election cycle did seem to
see a new resurgence and fiscal
conservatism among those under you know
the 18 to 25 crowd I'm wondering you
know when you said that you know the
government should use its money to
support social entrepreneurship it's not
really their money it's our money and so
I'm wondering how would you feel about
instead of the government you know
continuing to tax and then distribute
money as it sees fit but instead to
support a tax credit for supporting
people at the local level so if
example I could give you know the
computer Clubhouse you know money each
year and have that come off my taxes I
think we need to both I think we need to
do both I think tax credits are great
the reality is that there is a lot of
money in the government right now I
don't think it's being utilized as
affected I think part of the reason
there's been a backlash against
government involvement is because there
is there are big bureaucracies and and a
lot of funding is done politically I
mean you know earmarks are the best
example you know thirty billion dollars
that's all political money but even
within the existing system now I'm not
saying all government programs are bad I
just think that there is a new
competitive citizen sector Bill Drayton
is the guy who's really pushed this is a
genius who started Ashoka that's coming
into being there there is an
infrastructure now that didn't exist
certainly in 1935 it didn't even exist
in the 1960s of these social
entrepreneurs and more every day
and so there is a place now where
strategically even if you just open it
up to more competition there are a
number of places where as a social
entrepreneur you can't even compete for
the funding because you're not sort of
an established within the guideline
program so I think we need to do both I
think we should have tracks credits but
I think it would be amazing if you'd
even just took you know 2% of the
various federal departments and said
we're gonna have a what works fund or a
scale Social Innovation Fund and carbon
just a little bit of money for these
entrepreneurs that are inventing new
saloons they'd have to meet metrics they
have to get results you could even do
the funding based on you know if you're
if you say you're gonna teach more kids
to read and you don't get them to read
well then you lose your funding on a
much more competitive basis but I think
that's where we have to go because it
can't all be done by private
philanthropy there's just the resources
aren't there and even through tax
credits that the resources won't be
there that's why I think we need to sort
of look at both strategies
just as another model I should talk a
little bit about the Puget Sound off
funding situation because you don't
build a pretty ambitious web environment
for free and in the city of Seattle I
think should be credited they're one of
the partners in this project and when
they offered a cable license renewal to
Comcast they asked on Comcast to
contribute a half a million dollars to
public media fund for the city and then
it was decided that that youth
engagement would be the most suitable
deployment of that money and so the the
Comcast ended up paying for this
nonprofit commercial-free youth media
environment and I think that every city
could be thinking in these kinds of
terms I mean it's it's an easy model
cable environments our licenses are
incredibly lucrative and the question is
whether cities would think about funding
public media in various forms for
citizen engagement
I mean Seattle tends to invite citizens
to participate and so it's a fairly
active City and this is another example
of how that was supported my name is
David Wallace I have a day job as a
communications consultant for a company
called Game Change that I started and I
also teach journalism at Emerson College
this semester to teenagers the
fundamental issue of each or vegetables
nice to do versus got to do is a subject
I'd like you to address because the
basic nature of social network a lot of
these volunteer opportunities are things
that people want to do and they'll find
a way to make the time or make the the
income if they decide to pursue it as a
career but the extent to which youth as
a broadly over general term need instant
results things they want to do versus
things they have to do and use tools
particularly technology tools to the
extent that they're able as opposed to
challenging themselves to keep going
and learning more and doing more that
are issues of force rather than issues
of choice is an issue that I I see
students taking a path of least
resistance often times as opposed to
challenging themselves and I wonder if
that's an issue that you've seen in
terms of the eat your vegetables nice to
do versus got to do in engagement of
will only do as much as we really want
to but don't force us to do more for the
motivated students who make all of the
projects I'm involved with happen and I
understand that there that you know
service-learning sometimes becomes well
it's requirement and sometimes it's used
more to have a CV or resume than then it
is a serious commitment on the other
hand it does produce some lifelong kinds
of commitments the thing that I
discovered in our undergraduate intern
program is that the more I turned it
over to the students the more they
wanted to stick with it so I've got
students who don't get credit anymore
because they can't get any more credits
for doing internships who still are
there developing media skills and going
out and enjoying it and some of them
I've actually put on the payroll now so
I guess they figured out if they stick
around long enough they'll get a job but
it's wonderful because they keep me
motivated I mean I I end up being
energized by the fact that they are so
excited about being given the
opportunity to develop content and share
it with young people and see what's
working and go back to the drawing
boards and and make it better so that
process I think really gets them over
the a chirpies I mean I don't sense any
of that there none of them are there
I've got you know 75 or so interns a
year and I can't handle that many really
many of whom are not getting credit
anymore and they're out there doing
things and they show up and ask what
else they can do so I think there's some
motivation there and I don't say I see
these as exceptional human beings each
and every one but but I don't think
they're exceptional in terms of
you know that's all the number that
we're gonna get doing this stuff I think
it can scale pretty widely I should one
thing I would just add is that I think
one thing we find over and over and
working with youth but also people of
all ages is given the opportunity to
work on things they're passionate about
people will put an incredible amount of
time and you know in people who are seen
as having attention problems or lack of
interest will go deeply involved when
they work on things they're passionate
about but unfortunately many people
spend too much of their time work on
things they aren't passionate about and
we do see that with some of the
volunteerism today that sometimes people
are doing it because they're supposed to
be doing it or or you know they know
that it's a good thing to do but I think
that's one thing that can we take as a
challenge actually was restated a
conference with a lot of community
foundations who are addressing this
issue where they saw a rise in local of
young people volunteering but a lot of
times they weren't being matched up with
things they were passionate about and
this is one thing we then talked about
could there be a role for new technology
to try to help people match up with the
things they were passionate about so
there is this you know interest in
volunteering and you know if you can
find things do you really are passionate
about but it's not always easy to find
those and I think we need to do a better
job of help people find the things that
they're most passionate about and be
able to make the connections because I
think things will just work you know
when you can find us when the right
connections with passions yeah Mitch
stole all the good lines but I think I I
got them from him to begin with so
that's okay but I would say also that
this this is such a key component of the
education process whether it's in school
or in an after-school setting like a
clubhouse a skill it takes a skilled
teacher or youth worker to be able to do
those matchups and find out for the
various students children that they're
working with what what is that point how
to draw them out how to find what really
engages them what really gets them
excited and to be able to then work with
that
and encourage that and and often use
that enthusiasm to to learn other things
often we find that young people who get
involved in computer programming with
with a program like scratch which is a
very intuitive and and graphic way of
programming they start learning math and
stuff and they realize oh I just I just
did a math thing I didn't think I liked
math but so there are you know it but it
but it does take skilled human beings to
do that intervention technology that can
do that maybe but that I think that's
really key hi my name is Lana Swartz and
I'm a graduate student here at MIT and
I'm also a Teach for America alum so I'm
gonna be playing a little bit of devil's
advocate here even against my own
experience in some ways I thought it was
really interesting that the emphasis
from the first two projects was about
giving youth particularly
underprivileged youth the tools for
having a voice in us in the civic sphere
and the opportunity for service-learning
and the opportunity to grow from that
and the same thing goes though in the
latter in the Teach for America type of
programs and AmeriCorps city year the
stakes are much higher because young
people typically from a much more
privileged background are going beyond
media create creation to work in
communities and so I wonder then if the
primary goal is to provide service for
that community or to give those young
people the experience of full-time
citizenship of service-learning even as
they serve in communities that are much
less privileged than the ones they
likely came from so I wonder if you
could talk a little bit about how
important accountability is what does it
mean to be to go back to Mitch's
question a community organizer and you
have to be a member of that community
and then what constitutes community
membership
well thank you for your service to TFA
first of all that's that's tremendous
that that you committed two years of
your life to do that a couple things
first of all TFA is one model and I
think we need to have a range of models
you know city or for example we have
extremely diverse group of young people
they come from all different
socio-economic levels working class
middle class upper class all different
racial and ethnic backgrounds all
different face inner city and suburban
we've got former gang members working
alongside prep school graduates and and
our whole approach was actually to show
that national service can be a vehicle
to build common ground and bring people
together and there are a lot of
AmeriCorps program the youth build is
all another AmeriCorps program is on the
other end I mean TFA sort of on one end
city are sort of in the middle since we
are we're a vehicle for everybody
literally and then there's youth build
which is focused primarily on on young
people haven't made it through high
school and are getting training skills
both earning their GED and getting
training skills by building housing and
it the great thing about AmeriCorps is
it's got room for all of them and I
think we need room for all these
different kind of approaches there there
isn't one size fits all so I think
that's that's the first thing and I
think more programs need to be developed
that you know have some will be targeted
some won't some will involve everybody
in terms of you have to be from a
community in order to make change in
that community I don't think so I think
you have to one of the things we talk
about that city here is you know the
moccasins prayer Great Spirit grant that
I shall not criticize my brother or
sister until I walked a mile in his or
her moccasins you do have to have a
certain humility you have to have an
empathy you have to be willing to walk
in the moccasins of other people more
than a mile many miles to be effective
but I mean I've seen it with TFA alums
the interesting about city or is is that
because we have a diverse group and
wearing teams generally we always have
some young people on that team from that
community or from that background and
the interesting that happens is you know
we've got people who've gone to Harvard
and graduated they learn they're the
students from their peers who are from
that community because
you know obviously if you're from that
community if you've grown up in that
community you understand it you can
relate faster and that also interesting
dynamic that happens but they have to be
open to learning they've got to be open
to understanding so but I don't think
you know if we said you know I don't buy
that you have to be from a particular
neighborhood in order to be able to work
in that it or even for a particular
background you know we'd never be able
to get anything done if we said you know
you can only do that there are
strategies that work that way for sure
and they're needed but you know my
approach is everybody's got to get in
the game and by definition if we said if
you're from a privileged background
you're not needed well then we're we're
leaving out a whole set of people and we
need them and in fact ultimately I think
we've got to get the people who have
access to resources and have access to
power to care more about the people that
don't and the way to do that I think is
through national service and again not
just for that group I like models that
bring people together but you know
people don't just change they have to
have experiences and you know again I
believe if we had a program where people
were challenged to do this and if we had
more people of privilege serving they
would be more supportive of various
policies that will frankly realign
resources so that we can move from the
kind of just unbelievable disparity we
have in this country between the haves
and the have-nots which is getting worse
and worse and I again I think that's one
way to do it so I don't think yep
necessarily be from that community but
you have to have a certain humility and
an empathy and a willingness frankly to
learn and question some of your
assumptions but then you can be
incredibly effective if you if you if
you sort of meet those those tests
hi I'm tan B I'm a Brandon cognitive
science undergrad here at MIT and so
there's been this discussion kind of
local versus national versus
international I guess civic engagement
and how to get people involved could you
address maybe the problems of because
it's very easy to relatively to
encourage people to get involved locally
because there's a higher probability of
knowing the issues better knowing the
people the issues will affect but you
know particularly in the u.s. you know
nationally it's quite a big arena how do
you create a common conversation between
someone who lives in DC versus someone
who lives in the Midwest and even on an
international level someone who you know
lives on the other side of the world
that's a great question one of the
things I study when I'm not passionately
thinking about civic engagement for
young people is is social movements in
organization in the use of technology to
facilitate large social networks and and
I did a study with colleagues and seven
other countries of the global anti-war
protests on February 15th of 2002 which
is the largest organized protest in
human history so we serve traced it to
its roots and looked at both the in the
world
organizational foundations of that which
are important to understand that didn't
all just happen with technology but the
the technological facilitation was an
important part of scaling it so quick so
that the entire planning period I mean
if you think about protests in the
Vietnam War which is a comparable period
to go back to took months and sometimes
years to produce a half a million or a
million protesters this one took six
months to produce 20 million or so give
or take and in sixty some countries and
and the interesting thing about is when
we start going in we actually went into
demonstrations because we knew was going
to happen and we thought it was going to
be important to study so we went into
demonstrations in all of the
country's and handed out surveys which
we also were able to produce him if you
can imagine producing a survey
instrument in less than a month from in
these different languages with different
research teams with different agendas we
did all that through through technology
and and the thing that I found most
important was that there were meta
platforms that were quickly created and
they can be created very quickly that
enabled people to kind of lose their
organizational their modernist
organizational agendas and issues and
join in a common set of messages that
they could all live with one way or
another so the usual social movement
everybody else be on the same page and
share a collective identity which takes
years and usually doesn't work very well
sometimes it does didn't happen because
the these meta platforms enabled
people's organizational affiliations to
melt a bit and then the other thing that
we found that made the scalability so so
amazing was that individuals who who
were invited to free themselves up in
many cases from organizational
membership identities and the issue
straitjackets that sometimes go along
with those things were also freed up to
network with all of their friends
neighbors and and other activists and so
that individual level networking became
an important part I mean it was social
movement Theory often looks at
organizations and coalition's and
brokerage and all of those questions and
we found that it was the individual
activation of millions of personal
networks that seemed to be very
important for the scaling of this
protest the question of course is what's
the sustainability of movement type
formations given this loose tied set of
networks and that's another question but
but many of these protests have been
recurring in countries including ours
under the media radar because they're
not news they're not at least in this
country they tend not to be news but
they still continue to happen so I mean
that's kind of an example I think of how
technology and individual networking
become important yeah I've seen really
great examples in the web 2o world for
example of
of activism after the big tsunami that
hit Indonesia and after Katrina
there were various groups who were
formed who were making databases of
relief suppliers and to enable the
people who needed the relief to get them
in Katrina actually I was working on a
database effort from people all over the
country who were scouring various
websites and in many cases making phone
calls to find churches community centers
places that were opening and had beds
for people who who had no place to go
and we were putting all those things in
a database so that the Red Cross people
and various other people could access
that and and find central places so
there are good examples where the
technologies we have now on the internet
particularly but also in increasing ways
with cell phone technology to actually
organize people on our own a really
large scale and to get involved in a in
a much bigger effort I mean most of us
who who felt that we really would have
liked to help in the Katrina disaster
many people actually didn't go there
physically to help out but most of us
can't do that but but the internet and
and the new web tools allow that kind of
engagement now there's a few minutes ago
which is passion and I think that I
would also draw the sting screen between
sort of citizen service and civic
engagement
I obviously people have limited time and
so some people are gonna find when it
comes to sort of service work local
national international some people want
to work overseas some people want to
work on Nash
some people want to work right in their
own backyard and it's all about finding
your passion but I think when you think
of the other side which is being the
Harry Truman kind of highest office
citizen at least take the effort to
educate yourself and to join with other
voices on these issues I think
everybody's got to be a local national
and global citizen in today's world
you've you know because we have to start
building citizen power behind different
advocacy efforts I mean this thing about
20 million people in six well that's
extraordinary
but if you don't if you don't do both
it's not enough just to say you know I'm
gonna work volunteering in my kids
school or a neighborhood school if you
don't also care about education reform
policy at the local state and national
level because that's how education is
done you know all that volunteering will
never solve the education problem unless
you're engaging on the policy for you
know somebody climate change it's great
to you know get involved in a recycling
effort in your own neighborhood but if
you don't care about local state
national and global policy that's a
global problem if that's what you're
passionate about the problem won't get
solved so I think it's um it's sort of
in some ways just deciding what kind of
citizen you want to be you want a
service citizen but also then an
advocacy citizen just to correct the
record those protests occurred in 2003
hi I'm Justin Reich I'm at the Harvard
Graduate School of Education so I we
started up with Professor Bennet talking
sort of something Tamihere someone just
despairingly about schools and so I'd
love to go back to that for a minute and
think about as I've heard you sort of
talk about the skill sets that students
need for the kind of youth engagement
you're talking about or you there's sort
of two pieces there one of which were
these civic engagement skills and then
perhaps we want them doing it online
there's a series of kind of web 2.0 our
other kind of technological skills when
I hear about step it up and it was the
genocide Network
I mean one's being founded from
Middlebury the other being founded from
Haverford
so these are obviously some young people
who have some extraordinary educational
opportunities that they've had and you
know probably both I actually know at
least one kid from stepping up and you
know he went to some great schools and
had some great opportunities and I think
because of you know I think if we look
at the issues they're addressing it may
be that some of the issues are choosing
you address may come out of their
positions of privilege and out of the
extraordinary education that they've had
so what you know we may we may despair
about you know testing regimes and all
those kinds of things but are there
realistic things that our schools can be
doing in the near future to help youth
to help this issue of youth and civic
engagement sort of what's the role of
the public school system
that's that's realistic and possible
that we could be working towards they
could stop testing the life out of
students for one and and let students go
out into their community the formula for
how civic ed works in schools is pretty
simple peer based let the issues come
from the students deliberate about them
if you need to have a common issue to
study how policy gets made but then open
the doors and let the kids go out into
the community to learn about what's
going on there and that's a formula for
not a drudgery approach to civic ed but
for an exciting engaging one that may
have sustained effects on young people's
interest in their communities and
feeling that they can go out and do
something the trouble is that that's a
hard formula to get going and it tends
to occur more in affluent schools than
in poor schools for various reasons
teachers need more resources to help
kids do that in poor schools and they
tend to have the resources to enable
kids to do it in the richer schools but
if you do those things I mean schools
could be a fine environment just
figuring out how given our chaotic
school system and how many levels of
policy there are going on in it how to
make that attractive and even compelling
for more schools to do but schools could
work they just don't at the moment very
well
yeah I don't I don't even want to touch
the the issue of how to how to fix the
schools but yeah you know I I think at
all the Teach for America program is is
an interesting example I think what its
gonna take is really dedicated teachers
who who are allowed to teach and we know
that those dedicated teachers are out
there and we know that there are many
citizen advocates of better schools and
I think the less involvement with the
various levels of bureaucracy that
hamper the schools now the better
educators should be allowed to decide
what's a good education policy for our
schools hi my name is Toby I work at
WGBH in the interactive group there I'm
curious about the relationship and
changes to the relationship between
civic engagement and the subject of
history whether that's something taught
in a classroom or experienced through
documentaries or websites or books I'm
speculating from Lance's
characterization that in a dutiful
generation where voting was the primary
civic obligation that understanding your
history was also something approached
with a sense of duty and obligation and
whether if that was ever true is it not
now and if so how can we keep history
alive and make it useful and connected
to young people's lives
Ciel has been as a site of many
interesting historical events including
the WTO protests of almost a decade ago
and when those protests occurred a
number of colleagues got together and we
decided you know this is this is history
so how about we get our students to go
out and document the experiences of the
protesters you know Seattle created
Indymedia and there was all kinds of
captured
records of these protests they were just
sitting in laptops and cameras and so on
from the protest participants so we sent
teams out and and it was really exciting
for the students to go out and document
this history and then they helped
organize it and we got the library
interested in archiving everything from
posters to Turtle outfits that were worn
during the the protest and and digitally
create records of Turtle costumes so you
can spin them in the tree if you go to
the University of Washington libraries
then the WTO history project you'll see
a lot of digital archives and records
from about a hundred participants of all
sorts who were involved in these
protests so I think kids could I mean
you know recognize contemporary
historical moments that are important
and and sometimes these can be pretty
small but significant to communities and
go out and capture them that might be a
bridge to learning how to appreciate
other historical events more deeply I
have a question in relation about how is
the role of other people in order to
involve these young people much more how
would you saying but listening to you it
seems to me that there is a big question
in relation to intergenerational
relationship between people because for
example in Spain a big deal to involve
young people into new technologies is
how parents are thinking about that and
even we are models for young people he
says to me intergenerational question is
a big deal there and I will want to know
more about that about what you say them
that's a big thank you well I think we
we take the intergenerational issue very
seriously in in clubhouses and one of
the interesting things that comes up
sometimes particularly we we've seen it
for example in immigrant communities
where the young people are
English and the older generation often
don't know English when they come and so
now the young people are learning all
these incredible technical skills they
know English and it it makes the older
generation feel very disempowered so one
of the things we're trying to do is also
have the older people in many of the
programs work with the young people who
come to the clubhouse either separately
sometimes the parents don't like to
admit that they don't know this so they
don't know that so sometimes it's much
more empowering for the the older
generation of people to to meet together
by themselves or sometimes it works
better to work with it with the kids but
we we see that disparity a lot and it's
something that I think many club houses
are really trying to work to to bring
those to generate well too more than to
bring the generations together and to
empower them as well so that the the
young people as they're learning a lot
of skills don't outpace their elders and
make them feel somehow disempowered
my name is Alex Levin I'm an
undergraduate at Boston University
professor bettin everybody liked a
phrase that used which was effective
voice but at the last Communications
Forum event Cass Sunstein said that when
like-minded people come together it can
create some sort of violent chaos so I'm
wondering if there could be any kind of
detrimental youth voice and if it would
take over at any point or at least
become large enough to turn into a
threat against a more positive civic
engagement make sure I mean you could
imagine detrimental youth voice but I I
sense that there are tech you know we're
talking in a way about technology and
access to technologies that facilitate
some kind of collective intelligence so
that you know you can coordinate voice I
mean Howard rheingold's talked about
smart mobs and we can certainly in
Wikipedia suggests a youthful
intelligent voice in growing action and
and so I think the sort of creative
deployment of technologies that
facilitate intelligence gatherings of
large numbers of people taking action I
think the global war protests are an
excellent example of how pretty modest
technologies really scaled a large
action that was intelligently aimed I
mean that suddenly that you know the BBC
reported our press didn't but the BBC
did that suddenly public opinion is is a
power in this country I mean the largest
protest in history of London apparently
got the attention of politicians and and
the press
well the the witching hour has occurred
and I just wanted to say on behalf of
the communications forum the comparative
Media Studies program and the Center for
Future Sight media that this
conversation is exactly the kind of
thing that we're excited to have and
that all of you could participate or
many of you could is is really the point
of the exercise
it's not automatic that media
technologies will lead to civic
engagement and I think one of the main
things that we're all struggling for
people on this panel and those of us
here at MIT is to help facilitate that
process and not allow the voices of
negativity or the hate groups or whoever
to use these tools alone I mean it's
it's our duty to help provide the
opportunities in the mentorship and I
think the the generations can can work
together on that very effectively it
certainly isn't automatic it's all in us
to make it work so on behalf again of
the MIT communications forum Lance
Bennett Engelberg enter Allen KZ and
Mitchel Resnick thank you so much
you